hace un año el mundo descubrió bucha y
lo que pasó aquí
podría recordarnos Qué pasó
creo que ustedes se dan cuenta de que
nuestra ciudad de bucha no aspiraba
tanta notoriedad y reconocimiento de
parte de toda la comunidad pero después
de la invasión la gran escala de parte
de la federación rusa sobre territorio
ucraniano mucha fue sometida a la
ocupación y horrores que los habitantes
tuvieron que soportar
esto impactado al mundo entero cuando el
mundo civilizado descubrió la verdadera
cara de los rusos los habitantes de
bucha también quedaron impactados Rusia
es un país bárbaro un país terrorista y
en guerra contra la población Civil
ucraniana
las víctimas inocentes de bucha son el
resultado de una acción organizada por
líderes militares y políticos rusos que
trabajaron siguiendo listas efectuando
redadas dispararon a casi una persona
sobre tres llevaron a cabo una supuesta
campaña de intimidación contra el pueblo
ucraniano Pero fracasaron
algunas personas lograron irse y fueron
evacuadas
puede usted hablarnos del proceso de
evacuación
en realidad desde el primer día de la
invasión a gran escala comenzamos a
preparar la ciudad para los desafíos que
iban a suceder
no esperábamos que los rusos entraran en
la ciudad y la usaran como Rehenes
residentes bombardeando la ciudad de
no podíamos entender fue solo a partir
del 9 de marzo y hasta el 12 y 13 de
marzo que las supuestas caravanas de
autobuses para civiles lograron abrirse
paso
pero como luego descubrimos los rusos no
aceptaron los llamados corredores verdes
por lo que esas caravanas dispararon
contra las personas que intentaban irse
a lugares seguros
período por supuesto fue trágico y
difícil
porque una gran cantidad de personas
fueron simplemente fusiladas
asesinatos para diversión de los rusos
eran autos privados coches con cruces
rojas porque la Cruz Roja Internacional
y la Cruz Roja ucraniana acompañaron a
estas columnas
había muchos autobuses escolares que
tenían escrito niños sobre la carrocería
los rusos entraron en la ciudad y
sacaron a la gente pero al mismo tiempo
ellos mismos dispararon contra estas
columnas En otras palabras Rusia ha
violado de hecho todas las convenciones
internacionales
incluso cuando hace la guerra Rusia
lucha contra la población civil
cientos de personas fueron asesinadas
aquí algunas continúan desaparecidas
puede usted darnos una idea o decirnos
Quiénes eran qué les ha ocurrido
cada episodio es un crimen porque es un
asesinato premeditado
la gran mayoría de las víctimas presenta
impactos de bala en la cabeza tórax y
signos de tortura todo esto sugiere que
se actuó deliberadamente y no hubo
Víctimas de simples operaciones
militares como Rusia intenta retratar
Estos son delitos por los cuales los
rusos deben ser castigados por un
tribunal militar porque si esto no
sucede volverán a salirse con la suya
Como lo hicieron con los delitos
anteriores Entonces no habrá ni verdad
ni justicia en este mundo
desafortunadamente todavía tenemos
ciudadanos considerados desaparecidos
desconociéndose su destino Pero hay
otros hechos que indican que nuestros
ciudadanos están en cautiverio en Rusia
es decir se está llevando a cabo el
secuestro de civiles hacia la federación
rusa a través del territorio de belarus
lo que también es otro delito la
comunidad internacional debería condenar
tales cosas porque en el siglo XXI
secuestra personas como en la Edad Media
es inaceptable esto habla de lo que es
en verdad Rusia es una horda es un país
con un sistema dictatorial con
convenciones medievales incluso estando
en guerra Rusia lucha contra la
población civil
está recibiendo ayuda de la comunidad
internacional para investigar y
enjuiciar los crímenes de guerra aquí
puede contarnos más al respecto
para nosotros es sumamente importante
que cada episodio de asesinato de
violencia tenga su propio procedimiento
penal y que cada caso se ha llevado a un
tribunal internacional
de modo que cada episodio sucedido en mi
ciudad o en el territorio de Ucrania
donde las tropas rusas torturaron y
mataron a la población civil se ha
reflejado ante la comunidad
internacional
por esta razón desde el primer día de la
liberación la ciudad comenzó a trabajar
junto a las autoridades pertinentes
ucranianas e internacionales de Francia
lituania letonia y Estonia
Y actualmente especialistas de España
también están comenzando a trabajar para
brindar la asistencia adecuada
porque lo que pasó en bucha horrorizó al
mundo usted y yo no podemos imaginar lo
que está sucediendo en territorios donde
los rusos ocupan desde hace seis meses o
más Cuántas víctimas habrá y con cada
liberación de una ciudad ucraniana
veremos qué horrores dejarán atrás los
rusos
en cuanto a la investigación tenemos
algún avance podría identificar alguna
de las personas que cometieron los
crímenes
por supuesto hacemos todo lo posible
para ayudar a las autoridades
pertinentes a hacer su trabajo
esta semana Recibió la visita del fiscal
general de Ucrania con especialistas
quienes discutieron sobre el estado de
la investigación con más detalle
por supuesto fue agradable escuchar que
el sistema de aplicación de la ley en
este sentido ya tiene ciertos resultados
que los casos se llevarán a los
tribunales y habrá veredictos conocemos
las unidades conocemos a los soldados
rusos en esas unidades sabemos lo que
hicieron sabemos Dónde viven
conocemos a los sobrevivientes estando
en territorio ucraniano Espero que los
ejecutores y los líderes políticos y
militares que dieron estas órdenes sean
llevados ante la justicia
Ahora hay muchas personas que regresaron
a bucha que fueron evacuadas es una
ciudad que ha sido fuertemente destruida
puede darnos una de la escala de
destrucción que enfrentamos aquí
es sumamente importante tomar medidas
que traigan a los ciudadanos de regreso
a la ciudad
hoy estoy feliz de anunciar que más del
80% de los ciudadanos han regresado a mi
ciudad
es decir Hoy somos más de 40.000 y los
programas que estamos implementando para
restaurar el parque habitacional y la
infraestructura esencial inspiran la
confianza para que los ciudadanos
regresen a sus hogares al 100%
pero al mismo tiempo tenemos nuevos
desafíos relacionados con la migración
interna desde áreas donde se están
produciendo hostilidades
un cierto porcentaje de esos ciudadanos
viven en la ciudad de güecha
entendemos que este proceso es difícil y
largo
por lo que los aceptamos de la misma
manera en que se nos ha aceptado en
diferentes partes de Europa y el mundo